[Music]
go
then for you Togo here you see you're
rolling me here on the technique is
gonna turn to your shoulder down so you
in space
[Music]
his face call you okay he feels my
weight then details not why is it Ali
attention give up give this to Nabi
did let him do that's it that's all I
need
you get it that's all I need I could cut
my weight from there you can tell if you
listen little if you can't tell then he
goes top not right away right away means
you're carrying two inches into the
Kazushi okay let's go
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah okay now this was young so I have
to make it yeah I've been doing this way
internally tension releases I go around
Yong Yong
bull take this off the glue seated by
police so you can go wherever it's still
gone it's still y'all that's gonna be on
soon use that energetic relationship
[Music]
if you neutralize take don't think he'll
it's like hot here that gave hot cold so
I'm trying to find something ha ha ha
who keeps going or focal hole right this
started feel wrong
make it your writing okay you're not
ever doing what you want it's a ritual
we have animals eat but the Bulls not a
diagram in other words the rituals mama
by Maggie it's not two steps do you
understand that's how a ritual it
becomes dead that's what sound of the
modern religion there's no inner mystery
it's just awkward steps that's why he
comes there so what am I trying to do in
the form of a conciliation I have to
have before in order to train myself in
this skill because given dog exists
everywhere there's no places not even
young what the form does is sets up a
problem together you have to have a
particular ended on if you have a
particular agency
[Music]
I'm here right and I'm going to throw a
punch he's supposed to do a hit
reconciliation but if I punch him in the
face and his note shifts to the other
side of his head he can hit a
conciliation do that so it's not that
I'm doing good job it's a particular
duty dog so I keep the form so that
becomes relative so that I could develop
a skill and agency would give it on
reconciliation it's just straight class
philosophy okay so I'm doing it is not
and I'm doing it as you can I'm not
began I'm right I'm doing the same skill
the same exact skill energies coming at
me and I'm ready to side of it okay I
don't let it hurt us hence the same if I
hope you it's going to hurt okay
move yourself let's go wait move
yourself does that mean you start
calling yourself what is that
[Music]
there's a I have domination of my hotel
room and Hispanic across my defense
necklace any much shop I'm not to
initial ball you foul English alone you
got it if these hands aren't there I'm
gonna hit up I'm gonna ensure I'm the
other thing he's following the initial
block so party Tijuana's I have to do
nesting mess and find the technique
so where he should
yeah
[Music]
who
fires out
but inside right is educational products
because inside you have a prescriber
blue pushy
alpha one I do you don't measure some
stop okay okay you guys so back to your
question yesterday what's contagion
that's one thing that you could do on
these sender people eat red meat when
you feel me do that and you don't let
yourself subject be subject to contagion
now you tell me your own psychological
center disease both of us disengage
where before were supposed to and then
we think oh this is like an armbar okay
[Music]
No
[Applause]
[Music]
so part of the description is simply
don't land with this motion can keep
going into the technique you have to
scroll brother and then set up online
adjust my grid okay